y los núcleos y los hilos electro filos
son sumamente importantes en los
mecanismos de química orgánica primero
veamos al núcleo film la palabra núcleo
filo significa amante de núcleos y como
el núcleo está cargado positivamente
podemos pensar en un núcleo filo como
algo cargado negativamente porque
acuérdense que las cargas opuestas se
atraen entonces un núcleo filo puede
tener una carga completamente negativa
que será atraída por la carga positiva
del núcleo o puede tener una carga
parcial negativa o simplemente podemos
pensar que un núcleo filo tiene una
región de alta densidad electrónica
veamos algunos ejemplos de núcleo filos
empecemos con el año net óxido el año
net óxido tiene un oxígeno con una carga
negativa entonces ese es nuestro núcleo
filo y el oxígeno es el centro núcleo
físico del led óxido ahora veamos el
etanol bueno el etanol no tiene una
carga
ciertamente negativa pero sabemos que el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno así que el oxígeno jala los
electrones de este enlace para que estén
más cerca de él lo que le da una carga
parcial negativa entonces este oxígeno
es el centro núcleo físico del etanol
elanio net óxido es un mejor núcleo filo
que el etanol porque tiene una carga
formal completamente negativa a
diferencia de esta carga parcial
negativa ok y ahora veamos el metil
litio pensemos en la diferencia de
electro negatividad entre el carbono y
el litio vamos a ver el carbono es más
electro negativo que el litio entonces
los 12 electrones en este enlace se
encuentran más cerca del carbono y eso
le da al carbono una carga parcial
negativa por lo tanto el carbono es el
centro núcleo físico del metal litio y
como el litio pierde un poco de densidad
electrónica
podemos escribir una carga parcial
positiva aquí en el litio y bueno aquí
he puesto un enlace covalente pero en
realidad lo podemos mostrar como un
enlace iónico y miren la diferencia de
electro negatividad es tan grande que
puedo mostrar que los dos electrones se
encuentran en el carbono déjenme poner
los hidrógenos ok entonces como el
carbono es más electro negativo que el
litio podemos tomar estos dos electrones
de color rosa y colocarlos en el carbono
lo que le da al carbono una carga formal
negativa así que este carbono con una
carga formal negativa es el centro
núcleo físico y como le quitamos un
electrón a litio por eso tiene una carga
formal positiva entonces aquí hemos
representado un enlace iónico y aquí
tenemos un enlace más covalente y a esto
se le conoce como carbón yo lo escribiré
este es un carbón significa que tenemos
una carga negativa en el carbono y los
carbayones son excelentes núcleos y los
ok y finalmente veamos el ciclo externo
sabemos que el ciclo exc no tiene un
enlace pi aquí tenemos un enlace pi y
los enlaces pi son regiones de alta
densidad electrónica entonces este
enlace pi actúa como un núcleo filo en
un mecanismo de química orgánica
ahora veamos a los electro filos un
electro filo es un amante de electrones
y como los electrones están cargados
negativamente podemos pensar en que un
electro filo tiene una región de baja
densidad electrónica así que puede tener
una carga completamente positiva porque
las cargas positivas son atraídas por
los electrones o podemos hablar de una
carga parcial positiva entonces primero
analicemos este compuesto
sabemos que el cloro es más electro
negativo que el carbono así que el cloro
retira un poco de densidad electrónica
por lo tanto este carbono tiene una
carga parcial positiva es el centro
electro físico de este compuesto y ahora
veamos la acetona aquí el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el carbono entonces
el oxígeno retira un poco de densidad
electrónica
lejos de este carbono y por lo tanto
este carbono tiene una carga
positiva así que este carbono es la
parte electrónica de este compuesto ok y
ahora veamos un kart vocación aquí
tenemos una carga completamente positiva
en este carbono entonces este carbono
sólo tiene tres enlaces lo que le da esa
carga positiva y obviamente una carga
positiva ama a los electrones porque las
cargas supuestas se atraen por lo tanto
este carbono es la parte electrónica de
este ion y finalmente veamos este
compuesto
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el carbono retira un poco
de densidad electrónica
lejos de este carbono e incluso podemos
dibujar una estructura de resonancia
vamos a llevar estos electrones py al
oxígeno y vamos a dibujar una estructura
de resonancia aquí tenemos el doble
enlace y para mostrar que los electrones
peak se movieron al oxígeno ahora
tenemos tres
de electrones libres en este oxígeno lo
que le da una carga formal negativa y
como le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono que corresponde a este carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva
esta es una de las posibles estructuras
de resonancia que podemos dibujar y
claro sabemos que el carbono de color
rosa es un centro electro físico pero
podemos dibujar otra estructura de
resonancia vamos a ver voy a dibujar los
corchetes
si ahora movemos estos electrones y
hacia acá dibujemos la estructura de
resonancia que resulta aquí tenemos un
doble enlace después tenemos al oxígeno
con una carga formal negativa y por acá
tenemos el hidrógeno y claro nuestro
corchete ok y como ahora le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono de color azul
entonces este es el que tiene una carga
formal positiva el carbono en azul
corresponde a este carbono y tiene una
carga formal positiva y también es
electro filo verdad una carga
completamente positiva es atraída a una
carga negativa así que este compuesto en
realidad tiene dos centros electro
físicos que son este carbono y también
este carbono